TOLD INVESTIGATORS HE DID NOT
CHECK ALL THE ROUNDS LOADED IN
THE WEAPON PRIOR TO THE LETHAL
SHOOTING.
JOINLING US NOW, SHERIFF MENDOZA
AND DISTRICT ATTORNEY MARY
CARMACK.
SHERIFF, OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS
STILL AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION
BUT ARE YOU ABLE TO TELL US HOW
A LIVE BULLET GOT INTO THE GUN?
AND HOW -- HOW CLOSE YOU AND THE
FBI MIGHT BE IN DETERMINING WHAT
EXACTLY HAPPENED?
>> RIGHT NOW, WE CAN'T DETERMINE
EXACTLY HOW THAT LIVE BULLET GOT
INTO THE FIREARM.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE -- THE
BASIS FOR FURTHER INVESTIGATION.
WE NEED MORE INTERVIEWS AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE -- THE
MILLION-DOLLAR QUESTION IS HOW A
LIVE ROUND ENDED UP IN THE
REVOLVER THAT MR. BALDWIN FIRED.
>> AND, SHERIFF, HAVE BEEN
PEOPLE COOPERATIVE DURING THE
INVESTIGATION IN TERMS OF
TALKING ABOUT WHAT THEY KNOW?
>> INITIALLY, WE GOT STATEMENTS
FROM THE -- THE THREE
INDIVIDUALS -- MR. BALDWIN, MR.
HALLS, AND MS. GUTIERREZ.
WE WOULD LIKE TO GET FURTHER
STATEMENTS, AND MOST OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING
COOPERATIVE.
>> UM, DISTRICT ATTORNEY, YOU
TOLD CNN TODAY THAT KNOWING HOW
LIVE ROUNDS GOT INTO THE GUN
THAT MR. BALDWIN USED WILL BE
THE LYNCHPIN -- YOUR WORD -- ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO BRING CHARGES.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE TONIGHT ON
WHAT THOSE CHARGES COULD BE OR
AT LEAST WHAT PART OF THE
CRIMINAL CODE MIGHT APPLY?
>> NO, NOT AT THIS POINT.
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE TOO
PRELIMINARY TO -- TO START
FOCUSING ON WHAT THE CRIMINAL
CHARGES WILL BE BECAUSE WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHO -- WHO, IF ANYONE,
WOULD ACTUALLY BE CHARGED.
UM, YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY, WE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT OUR -- OUR
CRIMINAL CODE AND LOOK --
LOOKING AT UNINTENTIONAL
KILLINGS WHICH IN -- IN NEW
MEXICO IS CALLED INVOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER.
UM, BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO -- TO GET TO THAT
POINT.
WE JUST CAN'T MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION, YET, UNTIL THE
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETE.
>> AND -- AND, MADAM DISTRICT
ATTORNEY, WHO ON THE SET -- I
MEAN, IS IT CLEAR TO YOU AT
LEAST WHO ON THE SET OF THE
MOVIE HAD THE ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE SAFETY OF
THE GUN?
>> I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY A
QUESTION MORE FOR THE
INVESTIGATORS, FOR THE SHERIFF.
WE -- WE DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW
THAT, YET.
I THINK THAT WITH THE -- WITH
THE FURTHER INTERVIEWS THAT THE
SHERIFF INDICATED THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO, WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO COME -- GET A CLEARER PICTURE
OF THAT.
>> SHERIFF, YOU MENTIONED TODAY
THAT THERE WERE ADDITIONAL
ROUNDS FOUND IN THE GUN THAT YOU
BELIEVE ALEC BALDWIN FIRED.
DO WE KNOW IF THOSE WERE LIVE
BULLETS, AS WELL?
OR WERE THEY BLANKS?
>> RIGHT NOW, INDICATION ARE ARE
THEY WERE DUMMY ROUNDS.
SO, THEY WERE NOT SIMILAR TO THE
BULLET THAT WAS FIRED.
THEY WERE NOT SIMILAR.
THE CASING WAS SIMILAR BUT
THE -- BUT THE PRIMER WAS NOT.
SO, WE BELIEVE THAT THOSE WERE
DUMMY ROUNDS THAT WERE IN --
THAT WERE ALSO IN THE GUN THAT
MR. BALDWIN FIRED.
>> SHERIFF, HAS ANYONE EXPLAINED
TO YOU AT ALL WHY THERE WOULD BE
A -- A -- A BULLET -- A LIVE
ROUND ON A MOVIE SET?
>> NO ONE'S OFFERED AN
EXPLANATION TO THAT QUESTION.
AGAIN, WE ARE HOPING TO GET
FOLLOW-UP INTERVIEWS WITH THE
THREE INDIVIDUALS THAT HANDLED
THE LOADED FIREARM PRIOR TO MR.
BALDWIN TAKING POSSESSION OF IT.
SO, WE ARE HOPING TO GET FURTHER
INFORMATION ON EXACTLY WHY THEY
WERE THERE AND HOW THEY GOT
THERE.
>> SO, ARE -- ARE -- ARE THEY
BOOG BEING COOPERATIVE?
I MEAN, THE PEOPLE WHO WOULD
HAVE DIRECT KNOWLEDGE OF THAT?
CAN YOU SAY?
>> RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE BEEN
GETTING IN CONTACT WITH MR.
BALDWIN AND MRS. GUTIERREZ.
MR. HALL -- TO MR. HALLS, TO MY
KNOWLEDGE, HAS RETAINED LEGAL
COUNSEL AND WILL WORK THROUGH
HIS LEGAL COUNSEL TO HOPEFULLY
GET A FURTHER STATEMENT AND
CLARIFYING STATEMENT IN
REFERENCE TO WHAT HAPPENED.
>> AND, SHERIFF, THERE WERE SOME
REPORTS THAT CREW MEMBERS WERE
USING LIVE ROUNDS FOR TARGET
PRACTICE ON THE SET.
CAN YOU CONFIRM THAT?
>> WE HAVE HEARD THAT FROM
DIFFERENT SOURCES THROUGH THE
MEDIA, THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA, AND
OTHER SOURCES THAT THAT TOOK
PLACE.
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT --
THAT THAT HAS HAPPENED.
WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFICS OF WHERE
THAT TOOK PLACE AND WHEN IT TOOK
PLACE.
AND WE -- WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
ANYBODY WITH THAT INFORMATION TO
COME FORWARD TO THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
>> WERE THERE -- THERE
WEREN'T -- SO YOU ARE SAYING
THERE'S NOT OTHER LIVE ROUNDS
THAT YOU FOUND CARTRIDGES OF
ON -- AROUND?
>> THERE -- THERE ARE OTHER
ADDITIONAL SUSPECTED LIVE ROUNDS
THAT WE FOUND.
THAT'LL BE DETERMINED WHEN WE
SEND THOSE ROUNDS IN TO THE FBI
CRIME LAB FOR ANALYSIS.
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
POSSIBLY ADDITIONAL LIVE ROUNDS
THAT WERE ON THE -- THE SET.
>> ARE THEY -- CAN YOU SAY IF
THEY ARE IN THE CHURCH?
>> I WON'T -- I WON'T COMMENT
SPECIFICALLY WHERE THEIR
LOCATION WAS.
>> SURE.
>> BUT WHAT THEY WERE WITHIN THE
SPECIFIC CRIME SCENE THAT WE
PROCESSED.
>> HMM.
AND, MADAM DISTRICT ATTORNEY,
JUST FROM YOUR VANTAGE POINT, I
MEAN, FILMING HAPPENS OFTEN IN
SANTA FE ON -- ON THIS SET.
THERE -- THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER
FILMS.
I'D IMAGINE THERE ARE ON-SET
SAFETY PROCEDURES IN PLACE.
HOW SURPRISED WERE YOU THAT A
TRAGEDY LIKE THIS COULD OCCUR?
>> WELL, OBVIOUSLY, WE WERE
PRETTY SURPRISED THAT A TRAGEDY
LIKE THIS COULD OCCUR.
AND CERTAINLY THAT IT DID OCCUR.
THERE ARE SAFETY PROCEDURES AND
IT -- AND -- AND PROTOCOLS THAT
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FOLLOWED BY
EVERYONE IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE -- SEEMS LIKE
THAT THAT DID NOT HAPPEN IN THIS
CASE ON